si quelqu'un se pose aujourd'hui un
apôtre du cerveau droit c'est bien le
docteur Gilles Bolt et Taylor
ce qui lui est arrivé est incroyable un
matin de 1996 elle est victime d'un
accident vasculaire qui noie de sens son
hémisphère cérébrale gauche
j'ai été victime d'un accident
vasculaire cérébral dans cette région de
mon cerveau gauche
quand un vaisseau a explosé la lésion
s'est amplifiée et l'hémorragie ma
progressivement empêché de marcher
d'écrire de me souvenir du moindre
détail de ma vie or rappelez-vous le
docteur Taylor est neuro anatomiste avec
une étonnante lucidité elle raconte le
voyage qui depuis la lésion de son
hémisphère gauche la conduite
progressivement à découvrir les
potentialités de son hémisphère droit en
perdant l'usage de mon hémisphère gauche
j'ai perdu le souvenir de tous les
détails de ma vie c'est à dire les
informations relatives à mon travail à
mes relations tout ce qui est
constitutif de ma vie et de mes soucis
quotidiens tout d'un coup ce stress
s'est évanoui
il ne me restait plus que la conscience
et la beauté du moment présent et
c'était merveilleux
tout a changé alors
je suis passée dans un espace d'amour
d'ouverture de compassion de célébration
de la vie de gratitude pour l'être que
je suis
quand les médecins m'ont guéris quand
ils m'ont redonné l'usage de mon
hémisphère gauche quand j'ai pu à
nouveau communiquer et interagir avec
les autres je les fais en gardant le
souvenir de ce que j'avais découvert
dans mon hémisphère droit depuis
plusieurs années le docteur Bolt Taylor
porte la bonne parole du cerveau droit
ce cerveau qu'elle dit programmé pour
l'amour et l'ouverture à l'autre nous ne
sommes plus dans la science mais dans un
prêche quasi religieux fondé sur la
révélation que lui a procuré son
accident cérébral
je fais l'hypothèse que la religion est
un mode d'accès à l'hémisphère droit de
notre cerveau
elle nous permet d'aller au-delà de
nous-mêmes de méditer sur les questions
essentielles de notre existence sur son
sens de nous arracher ou tumulte de
notre hémisphère gauche à cette activité
fébrile pour explorer une zone où nous
sommes plus détendus plus authentique
plus introspectif
c'est ce que les gens recherchent de
plus en plus ils sont tellement
contraints par leur hémisphère gauche
qu'il recherche cet espace de
tranquillité et de paix et c'est ce que
nous apporte l'hémisphère droit
l'hémisphère droit nous connecte à la
dimension de la spiritualité il nous
ouvre à une vision globale qui abolit
les limites
et quand les frontières disparaissent on
est offert à la totalité de ce qui
existe on sent la présence de quelque
chose qui est plus grand que soi
on l'appelle Bouddha Dieu Allah peu
importe car cette présence est là en
nous dans la conscience de notre
hémisphère droit
[Musique]